They're all doing it for the purpose of saving lives.
When my own father collapsed a few years ago
from a cardiac arrest, one of the first volunteers
to arrive to save my father
was one of these Muslim volunteers from east Jerusalem
who was in the first course to join Hatzalah.
And he saved my father.
Could you imagine how I felt in that moment?
When I started this organization, I was 17 years old.
I never imagined that one day I'd be speaking at TEDMED.
I never even knew what TEDMED was then.
I don't think it existed, but I never imagined,
I never imagined that it's going to go all around,
it's going to spread around,
and this last year we started in Panama and Brazil.
All I need is a partner who is a little meshugenah like me,
passionate about saving lives, and willing to do it.
And I'm actually starting it in India very soon
with a friend who I met in Harvard just a while back.
Hatzalah actually started in Brooklyn by a Hasidic Jew
years before us in Williamsburg,
and now it's all over the Jewish community in New York,
even Australia and Mexico and many other Jewish communities.
But it could spread everywhere.
It's very easy to adopt.
You even saw these volunteers in New York
saving lives in the World Trade Center.
Last year alone, we treated in Israel 207,000 people.
Forty-two thousand of them were life-threatening situations.
And we made a difference.
I guess you could call this a lifesaving flash mob,
and it works.
When I look all around here,
I see lots of people who would go an extra mile,
run an extra mile to save other people,
no matter who they are, no matter what religion,
no matter who, where they come from.
We all want to be heroes.
We just need a good idea, motivation
and lots of chutzpah,
and we could save millions of people
that otherwise would not be saved.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)